impossible de passer à côté panneau
publicitaire affiche de campagne
les élections législatives enjeux
majeurs du futur printemps néerlandais
une nouvelle saison marquée par
l'empreinte du coc vide 19 sujet dans
toutes les têtes des politiques et des
votants je pense qu'il y à des
discussions sur d'autres sujets mais
bien sûr principalement sur le
coronavirus l'impact des mesures et les
décisions sont la crise du coc vides
font bien évidemment partie du débat
donc cela laisse moins de place à
d'autres sujets le parti libéral vvd est
au gouvernement depuis un certain temps
et je pense qu'il a eu beaucoup de
scandales auxquels ils n'auraient
peut-être pas survécu si le coronavirus
n'était pas là par exemple celui autour
des allocations familiales c'est très
important et je ne pense pas qu'ils
auraient pu avoir autant de sièges
si le coronavirus n'était pas là le
parti populaire pour la liberté la
démocratie de marque route eu en tête
des sondages dirige une coalition de
quatre partis celui de l'appel chrétien
démocrate celui de l'union chrétienne ou
encore le d66 de centre gauche un
gouvernement pourtant démissionnaire
début janvier une vingtaine de milliers
de famille accusée à tort de fraude aux
allocations familiales
toujours au pouvoir et en charge des
affaires courantes jusqu'à la tenue des
élections le premier ministre marcourt
ou te joue la carte de la prudence et de
l'espoir face au co vite sceptiques
[Musique]
depuis le 1er mars les salons de
coiffure et de massage en rouvert tout
comme partiellement les lycées et
collèges
malgré un couvre-feu de 21h à 4h30 du
matin prolongé jusqu'au 31 mars locaux
vides 19 qui tend à éclipser d'autres
problématiques
selon le chef de la seconde formation
politique du pays
d'autres questions comme l'immigration
sont aussi importantes pour mes
électeurs c'est toujours la question
numéro 1 mais pour le néerlandais moyens
le coc vider sa principale préoccupation
le premier ministre a exclu d'inclure
dans son gouvernement le parti de geert
wilders
très actif sur les réseaux sociaux
pandémie oblige le parti de la gauche
verte groenlinks espère lui pouvoir
rejoindre la future coalition au pouvoir
marc route de 54 ans est l'un des
dirigeants européens ayant la plus
grande longévité à ce poste
l'homme a entamé sa onzième année à la
tête des pays bas